alors voir que l'avare que j'ai fait
hier dans les journaux je viens de faire
aujourd'hui en personne c'est le cri du
coeur de nationalisme qui prend ses
distances du Parti libéral dans l'espoir
de secouer le pommier maintenant les
gens qui sont à l'intérieur faut qu'il
évite le piège du confort il faut qu'il
prenne les positions les plus
inconfortables qui soient pour aller
vers le centre pour aller vers cette
électeur là à mon sens francophone
nationaliste libéral et Jérôme Turcotte
n'est pas le seul à s'inquiéter aide
nationaliste au PLQ c'est comme être
peckes dans Dolce on sent un peu seul
des fois apprendre la parole puis à se
dire moi la défense de la langue
française c'est important moi la défense
des valeurs québécois c'est important
non je crois pas je crois pas du tout à
l'heure ou un comité de relance tente de
redéfinir ce que signifie être libéral
en 2023 la question apparaît aussi
importante qu'en battante moi ce que je
constate c'est que si Jérôme a décidé de
quitter j'en ai 400 et même plus qui ont
décidé d'être ici et de débattre et on
va travailler avec ceux qui veulent
débattre justement en train de faire une
initi arrive donc faire une démarche qui
qui va permettre aux gens de pouvoir
s'exprimer sur cette question-là
[Applaudissements]
sur le thème de l'affirmation du peuple
québécois les militants en avaient
d'ailleurs long à dire nous sommes le
seul parti qui est résolument canadien
alors ne nous gênons pas pour le dire
arrêtez de parler de nationalisme au PLQ
parlons plutôt de patriotisme la fierté
un moment donné quand il y en a trop ça
se transforme en arrogance et en orgueil
l'autre sujet qui est sur toutes les
lèvres c'est la course à lâcher Free et
même si des candidats potentiels font
mine de ne pas trop y penser certains
sont plus précis que d'autres
devrait se faire plutôt que tard pour
justement permettre à le ou la prochaine
chef de pouvoir avoir les coups de
franges rapidement de se faire connaître
le jour où on va terminer ce travail
avec le comité de relance oui la course
va ramener aussi dans tes bas d'idées
mais il faut faire les choses une étape
à la fois il est peu probable que la
course à la direction soit déclenchée
avant 2024 voire 2025 puisque les règles
n'ont pas encore été présentées aux
membres du parti ici alexandre Duval
Radio-Canada Victoriaville
et on retrouve notre chef de bureau de
Québec à Victoriaville Sébastien est
visiblement un parti qui se cherche en
cas d'identité et rarement on a vu chez
les libéraux ce type de débat et de
différents publics
oui ça provoque la division ça provoque
la résistance il y en a qui sont venus
appuyer la position de Jérôme Turcotte
en disant le Parti libéral devrait
exercer ouais exprimer un nationalisme
plus assumé plus revendicateur mais il y
en a d'autres qui sont allés au micro
aussi pour dire genre ma patrie c'est le
Québec mais mon pays c'est le Canada
faire une profession de foi fédéraliste
signe donc que ces fameux ponts que le
Parti libéral veut rebâtir avec le vote
francophone va être extrêmement
difficile à ériger c'est aussi que le
comité de relance vous savez qui est
qu'aux présidé par l'ancien journaliste
André Pratt va devoir faire une espèce
de grand écart entre ce qu'il reste la
base électorale libérale c'est-à-dire
l'ouest de l'île de Montréal et ce
fameux vote francophone et l'enjeu est
important que Claudine c'est de
présenter le Parti libéral comme une
alternative c'est de freiner le déclin
du Parti libéral et l'impression qu'il
se dégage de la journée d'aujourd'hui
c'est que il y a beaucoup de militants
qui sont peut-être pas prêts à donner un
électrochoc à leur partie bon et on ne
s'entend pas non plus sur le moment
sortir pour déclencher une course à la
direction alors pourquoi les règles se
font-elles attendre
parce qu'il y a deux écoles de pensées
sur le moment où on doit déclencher la
course à la direction du Parti libéral
il y a l'école des pressés puis l'école
n'est pas pressée il y a plus de monde
dans l'école des pas précis des gens qui
disent attendent attendons la limite ou
attendons le plus possible pour
déclencher cette course à la direction
dans l'espoir que quelqu'un de
l'extérieur du parti va se manifester
c'est en dit peut-être un peu sur ceux
qui ont déjà manifesté de l'intérêt
notamment le chef par intérim Mark
Tanguay ou les députés mon chef des
ragies André Fortin ou Frédéric
Beauchemin des gens du Parti libéral
espèrent peut-être que quelqu'un de
l'extérieur va venir porter sa
candidature et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a l'impression que la course
sera probablement retardée le plus
longtemps possible fin 2024 début 2025
pour trouver un nouveau chef du Parti
libéral merci beaucoup Sébastien bonne
soirée bonne soirée